come on we all know marble is perfect
and flawless that was a joke don't slam
me in the comments right off the bat so
I want to talk about the idea of Marvel
regaining the rights to x-men because
the idea that they should I have seen
crop up over and over and over again
whenever I have talked about Fox's use
of the x-men as a property and their
handling of it as franchise and a lot of
people just seem to be chanting let
Marvel have x-men back let Marvel have
x-men back and I don't actually think
that's a good idea
and I say that not going Fox has been
perfect because they have it Fox has
screwed up a lot and I've already got my
video out there as to how I think they
are already screwing up Dark Phoenix and
I expect that to suck but that doesn't
mean I want Marvel to take back x-men
and there's a couple of different
reasons for that the first has to do
let's be fair with what Fox has done
right which lately has been the spin-off
material and I'm going to focus mostly
on Deadpool Logan because the simple
fact is both of those are movies that
would not be made under the direct
Marvel banner because Marvel is owned by
Disney and while Disney is happy to go
r-rated on the Netflix stuff as far as
stuff being released to movies
Marvel is still associated with the
Disney brand Disney would never have
greenlit Deadpool they never would have
greenlit Logan and whether or not you
think those are amazing and flawless
movies they're not though both of them
are very very good the fact remains that
we should have this kind of variety we
should have superhero movies that are
catering to an explicitly adult audience
because if we don't have this kind of
variety then superhero movies are going
to die a lot sooner than is necessary
because I love these movies and I want
this trend of superhero and comic book
based films to last as long as it
possibly can and the quick thing that
will kill it is stagnation and what is
going to be stagnating is if they all
seem the same and an easy way for them
all to see is a scene the same
is if they are all aiming at the same
pg-13 demographic by having some that
are rated we get to spread it out we get
to show that they are more than just
this one thing and another way for
everything to see the same and have it
start to stay a is by having it all
under the same studio so beyond just the
fact that I want to acknowledge the
things that Fox had done and done right
that Disney would not do I also want to
address just the broad reasons that even
if that wasn't the case even if Fox had
done nothing but screw these movies up
for the last four or five films I still
wouldn't want Marvel to regain the
rights back and here's why
because at this point the only benefit
to Marvel having the rights bag is to
integrate the x-men into the MCU and I
get that a lot of people want that but
it's actually a good idea in my personal
opinion it really isn't so here's the
thing about x-men and the thing that is
a little bit weird about it
even though the x-men and I'm talking
about the comics now even though the
x-men exist in the Marvel Universe and
in the same space as Avengers and all
this other stuff they've kind of always
been kept in their own bubble and they
work best that way really in terms of
the comic books you can break down the
vast majority of Marvel's universe into
three categories Avengers heroes cosmic
heroes x-men heroes and for the most
part those three universes don't cross
over very much and when they do they
actually make a really big event out of
it it ends up being something like
infinity war where the cosmic heroes
come down to earth or in terms of x-men
crossing over with the rest of the
heroes you get something like x-men vs.
Avengers or House of M these big massive
events in the company itself seems to
acknowledge that the idea of everything
that goes on in the x-men because that
is a massive cast in and of itself
crossing over with the rest of the
Marvel Universe is a big deal because
they are so often kept separate part of
it is just the sheer volume of
characters the thing that's been
ridiculous about Sony looking to create
a whole cinematic universe around just
spider-man is that as ultimate
spider-man is and as great as the
supporting cast is it really all
revolves around that one single
character that's not the case with the
x-men it makes sense
that the x-men is resulting in spin-offs
and new media and all the stuff because
the cast of mutant characters is
absurdly huge so part of it is I'm just
not honestly sure if there is room in
one cinematic universe for the x-men to
actively be crossing over with Avengers
and I think if the Marvel were to
require the x-men and they were to say
that it's happening in the same universe
well you can't have to have them cross
over because they're all occupying the
same space the comics don't really
address the fact that you know the x-men
are dealing with these world-threatening
and comic book readers kind of accept it
on a we won't bring it up if you won't
basis I'm not sure mainstream audiences
will go for that if you do establish all
these people are occupying the same
space and if you're thinking that you
can just we'll just keep it separate for
the most part it's working with
guardians the galaxies and the cosmic
stuff that hasn't crossed over and been
an issue with the Avengers stuff yet but
that's because there's an inherent
natural barrier between the cosmic stuff
and the rest of the MCU which is that
it's in space it's physically very very
very far away so you actually have to go
out of your way to bring them together
as opposed to go out of your way to
explain why they have to be kept
separate which would be the case with
x-men and the MCU and then there's all
the logistical ideas of trying to
integrate the mutants into the MCU
because the whole thing that really
drives home the point with mutants x-men
all of that is that mutation is a fill
in it is a substitute to represent any
minority that is oppressed undermined
ignored or otherwise stepped on I mean
where the heck of mutants been we've had
the MCU for almost a decade now and
there's been no mutants to suddenly
introduce them you're gonna have to
spend so much time just explaining why
we've never brought this up before and
you're just going to lose the entire
just you know civil civil rights
oppressed group angle to the thing which
really is vital to the x-men identity as
a franchise not every individual
character some of them couldn't give a
crap
but that is really central to the whole
thing if they haven't just been around
and been something that people have had
to deal with then that analogy becomes
all the more ham-fisted and awkward if
it even works at all
and as I said trying to integrate all
the x-men characters into the MCU
actively and have them continuously
crossing over weird Avengers characters
on any kind of regular basis is going to
be such a mess and a cluster it would
just make more sense to give them more
or less separate but if you're keeping
more of the more or less separate why
don't I have to be in the same cinematic
universe anyways just let clark's keep
them now could Fox be doing a better job
absolutely like I said the spin-off
stuff is looking pretty good right now
but their main franchise apocalypse I I
didn't hate it at the time I saw it but
I think less and less and less of it
every time I think about that movie and
like I said I've already done a video
talking about why I think Dark Phoenix
is doomed to failure but I do alternate
Leath inc it is a good thing for x-men
as a franchise for DMC you and for
superhero movies as an overall thing but
these two things be kept separate and
crossover like I said that is more or
less how it happens in the comics and no
don't start citing the examples of whoa
this time that the Punisher met
Wolverine and this time that Spiderman
fought alongside because I understand
that they do crossover but it's not
nearly with the same level of casualness
that you know various Avengers
characters crossover with each other or
very section main characters crossover
with each other they are very much kept
separate and when they meet up it's a
big deal and while there would be some
fun to be had in making a big deal out
of having them all meet up I just think
it's ultimately going to a completely
clutter and make the MCU almost
unmanageable and deprive us of a much
more potentially unique voice as a
contrast to what Marvel is doing with
his characters because like I said at
the beginning Marvel and Disney would
not have made Deadpool and they
definitely would not have made Logan and
that's why as much as I don't want them
to make any more bad movies I'm happy
that Fox still has this property and I
want them to keep trying I don't want
them to give up and I want them to be
sure that what they're doing is not just
trying to do the same thing that Marvel
doesn't they are
your own thing and so far pass or fail
they have been doing that so keep doing
that
give us the variety give us not
everything that feels the same and look
I understand for x-men fans that Fox has
botched some of these characters 'm some
of these stories badly and you are angry
about that and you believe that Marvel
would do it right and maybe they would
if they'd had control of these things
from the beginning but at this point the
MCU is too far along to well-established
would it have worked if Marvel had
control of x-men at the time they
started the MCU maybe it's too late now
ships sailed and there are good things
that have come out of that
so I say embrace it don't root for Fox
to fail root for them to get it right
because let's be honest when they get it
right they get it really right they just
need to work on their you know win to
loss ratio so those are the reasons that
I think the idea of Marvel regaining the
movie rights to x-men would not be a
great thing what are your thoughts on
all this whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher
I am also one half of the punch like a
girl podcast also available on iTunes
and stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]